c'est durant les vacances de noël le 19
décembre dernier que la nouvelle miss
france a été couronnée en direct depuis
le puy du fou
miss normandie cérémonie qui a cartonné
puisque 8,6 millions de français ont
assisté au couronnement de miss
normandie
amandine petit si la soirée était à la
fête sur les réseaux la célébration
s'est transformé en déferlement de haine
avec une pluie de commentaires
antisémites à l'encontre de sa première
dauphine
april benayoun miss provence et alors
que le renne d'amandine petit vient de
débuter ce week-end une séance de
dédicaces dans un centre commercial de
moselle a enflammé la toile une séance
durant laquelle des milliers de
personnes étaient réunies sans aucune
distanciation social que non réélus ont
fait entendre leur colère qu'un tel
événement soit maintenue de la sorte
alors comment notre nouvelle miss france
vittel son couronnement ce soir sylvie
tellier amandine petits sont avec nous
et elles répondent à toutes vos
questions
miss france est avec toi amandine petit
merci d'être là rencontre et bien sûr
j'ai suivi la cérémonie
sylvie ma chérie comment ça va et là
c'est la bonne année ça va bonne année
masculine alors je vais au téléphone
sylvie jeudi bonne année et ben voilà
elle était dans le jury
1 on s'envoyait des petits sms on peut
le dire voilà mon sens [ __ ] pc mais
cela pendant la cérémonie
nathalie qui étaient avec nous est ce
que vous aviez voté pour ramon dit la
vérité
alors moi je vais vous dire la vérité
oui au démarrage généré pour miss côte
d'azur au démarrage
on va passer sous enseigne par sms
exactement mais oui c'est vraiment mais
amandine sais pas du tout ce que vous
croyez
eh bien je perds tout de suite mais par
la suite au moment elle a pris la parole
elodie gossuin à côté de moi et je dis à
ce pour moi c'est elle miss france et
amandine je vous dis et je pense que
s'il y est d'accord avec donc je pense
que vous avez fait la différence
vous avez pris la parole à la fin c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
dit à attention amandine elle a un truc
en plus mais elle a signé est-ce que
vous qui connaissez
mine de rien vous connaissez très bien
le la cérémonie est ce que vous vous
êtes dit tout de suite
enfin quand vous voyez les cinq six
dernières minutes c'est ce que vous êtes
des sermons dean qui va gagner
alors moi je ne vois jamais la miss
france est vraiment pas très doué pour
pour savoir qui va être élu et
franchement cette année on avait quand
même une super promo et sur les cinq
finalistes pense qu'on avait cinq miss
france donc
alors que cette année sera candidat
croyant évidemment c'est la différence
un moment donné téléspectateurs ont dû
ressentir mais je tiens à dire qu'on
avait quand même cinq jeunes femmes sur
scène qu était sacrément est difficile
amandine à chaque fois on va revoir
votre sacre alors moi à chaque fois je
suis un peu déçu pour la première
dauphine
mais c'est vrai parce qu'à chaque fois
c'est le truc où la jeunesse
complètement au travers
la pauvre franchement en plus je
l'adorent on va en parler dans un
instant de la première dauphine parce
qu'il ya une petite polémique concernant
la première dauphine a égalé si vous
étiez à égalité avec miss provence a
c'est la première c'est pas loin assis
s'est apprécié après c'est bien appris
vous étiez égalité et dans ce cas là
quand il ya inégalité sylvie public et
ses animaux exactement donc le public
avait voté plus pour amandine miss
normandie
on va parler d'après l'un dans un
instant regarder votre sac ça ça doit
être un truc de fou compté à deux comme
ça hein c'est comme moi quand j'ai fait
plus mr djerba miss france 2000 21e et
restera miss normandie
benzema est lui cependant cette année
encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo à vue samedi et bravo à toutes
[Musique]